this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development before we begin I'd like to
take an opportunity to introduce Carissa
little Carissa is the director of
professional programs at the Stanford
center for professional development she
has been with the Stanford with Stanford
University for ten years and is
responsible for collaborating with
Stanford faculty industry experts and
corporate partners to develop their
professional and executive programs that
extend Stanford to industry
she worked in both software and
education prior to come to Stanford
welcome Carissa Thank You Stacey if my
pleasure to also introduce professor
bill Burnett he is a consulting
assistant professor professor in
mechanical engineering and currently the
executive director for the design
program welcome bill hi Stacey
great at this point let's begin thank
you hi this is Bill this is um so the
concluding webinar for a series we've
been doing on design thinking and a
bunch of really interesting topics I've
been very happy to have my colleagues
join me for a series of webinars all of
which are up on YouTube we've had ones
on radical collaboration and redefining
the automobile with the cars group at
Stanford we build up we did a design
thinking and peak performance and also
one on transforming teams which uses the
principles of design thinking to extract
you know more innovation and more
excitement out of your development teams
and we've also looked at design thinking
both as a strategic tool and as a method
of sort of frame working how innovation
happens in organizations so when Stacey
and Chris asked for one more webinar I
was thinking well what could we possibly
talk about that we haven't already
spoken up so I thought well we'll just
let's zoom back let's zoom back to
10,000 feet and ask some big big
questions that really face everyone who
works in any kind of mark
so here's a picture of how you might
feel if you were you know a CEO a
director a manager of a big project or
even just someone trying to make an
important decision today you're stopped
standing on top of this mountain of
facts
hopefully in opinions and emotions and
you're about ready to let go a little a
little bolder and depending on which
side of this mountain you're let going
you're going to end up in very very
different places and this is a really
lovely little sketch that my colleague
Danny Banerjee always uses to describe
really the sort of simplest possible
view of what is it that management does
and zooming back even farther what
really is the unit of analysis that we
think about when we talk about big
questions well you know what is the
company you know what what what what is
the company why why is there such things
as companies you can zoom in a little
bit closer and say what is a project and
when you really look at these things
from a very fundamental point of view
you realize that they're all really just
the same thing a company a project
something that you want to organize and
accomplish is a little Nexus of economic
activity at least in the business world
it's about economics some energy some
information some ambiguity goes into
this Nexus and out comes a series of
decisions hopefully that result in a
better economic situation than when the
project or the company started but you
really have to ask yourself you know
some big quest like why why are we doing
this project and what does this project
mean why does my company even exist and
what does my company mean if you want to
read an interesting book again in Robert
Brunner I had the privilege of working
with Apple Robert actually started the
design studio at Apple many many years
ago probably pecking around
495 prior to that Apple did not have a
studio design is though it's considered
to be one of the top design companies in
the world today Apple used to rely
solely on outside consultants for all of
its design inspiration and I was working
at Apple for about seven years when we
decided to bring a design in-house and
ran an international competition and
selected Robert Brunner who at the time
was principal in a firm called lunar
design he came in he started the studio
at Apple hired a young kid named Johnny
Ives who has since gone on to quite a
bit of fame and fortune with them his
relationship with Steve Jobs and the
Fantastic design work that he has
created at Apple and has created the
social sense that Apple was responsible
for everybody all of a sudden being
interested in design but Robert wrote a
book called do you matter and so looking
at looking at a bunch of different case
studies that he and Stewart Emory
collected about what companies actually
mean to their customers because if you
think about this little nexus of
economic activity there's only you know
two things going on there's somebody
creating an offering and there's
somebody deciding to purchase it and
what what Bob Brunner asks is the
question you know if your company went
away tomorrow would anyone care it's an
interesting question to ask because I
think if you said gee if Apple just you
know a meteor hit Cupertino and there
was no more Apple Computer would people
care I think there would be a lot of
people in the world that we really care
if BMW stopped making automobiles or if
Harley stopped making motorcycle legions
of loyal fans would really really care
and then the question Bruner Aston goes
through in the book and more detail is
you know are you that kind of company
and what are the qualities of a company
that creates that kind of passion and
loyalty in their and their consumers and
so one of the big questions you got to
ask yourself is what are you doing
why are you doing it and does it matter
that's what I want to talk about here
because Design Thinking impacts that
framework a bit um in the old days when
we talked about design in the old days
being maybe the 90s now we know we must
never talk about the design of objects
and artifacts maybe you know if you were
a very avant-garde company you were
talking about the design of services but
in the last 10 years certainly in the
last decade and clearly since the
founding of the d.school here at
Stanford which is our sort of graduate
level graduate student teaching
Institute where we're teaching Design
Thinking to everyone on campus and and
literally to people all over the world
Design Thinking has changed its its the
emphasis from design to things like
systems and business strategies and what
we call interventions places where
design moves into a large-scale system
or pattern and intervenes for instance
we're doing things there's a huge
epidemic of childhood obesity in the US
and in Western Europe primarily caused
by poor nutrition junk food sugar candy
sodas things like that creating not only
obese children but children who when
they grow up or at risk of diabetes and
other illnesses and we're doing a lot of
design solutions to intervene in that
obesity epidemic and certainly design
now is being used to create visions of
the future so this whole transition from
designs of design thinking has really
been fundamental in moving people to
using design in their organizations in
very different ways so people think
about design in the old way a sort of a
way of solving problems you designed
your way out of a problem but really
design thinking is much more of a way to
find new problems
find and frame problems in a creative
way so that the solutions you generate
are really new new strategies new
systems and new paradigms and they're
generally in between domains or very
multidisciplinary in their nature so I
mean the term paradigm a paradigm shift
and it's a new paradigm is pretty
overused and I want to make sure we
understand what we're talking about when
we use the term paradigm in a design
thinking context and this is a fantastic
slide by Richard Pascale and his
colleagues that we're looking at
paradigm shifts and for the purpose of
illustration
they used the high jump as a methodology
today people are jumping you know
somewhere between 90 95 98 inches and
height which I just find astonishing you
know I'm six one and these people are
jumping over my head by a couple of feet
but in the early part of the of the 20th
century in the 1900s the Olympic records
were in the 70 inch 70 mid 70 inch range
and people use what was called the
scissor kick they literally jumped
straight up with their butt going over
the bar and their legs scissoring to
provide some lift and leverage they were
also landing on straw mats which are
rather hard couple technology changes
the mats got a little softer and people
invented the Western roll which is a
means of sort of rolling your body over
the bar by lifting your outside leg up
high lifting your body over and then
rolling over the bar and you can see
that what happened is the Western roll
just was a whole new paradigm for high
jumping and the heights went up sort of
significantly in that period
then came the straddle kick a straddle
kick was a big innovation a Hugh
versed in heights went from you know the
mid 80s with low 80s to the mid 80s and
inches also improved maths at this point
added some extra technology to the game
and people could land in a more
precarious position and finally it was a
guy named dick Fosbury who had not been
a particularly successful high jumper in
college but he invented a method of
going over the bar headfirst and landing
on his neck this of course would have
been impossible without the technology
of foam mats and other things that were
that were then allowed to increase the
safety of the high jump in international
competition but the Fosbury flop
resulted in a huge burst of new records
and you know propelling people well into
the 90s category so you can see what
happened in each of these different way
completely different ways of approaching
the kinematics of lifting your body over
a high bar and recognizing that in each
case some new technology enabled a new
approach you see what we're talking
about when we talk about a paradigm
shift and the paradigm shift from design
as a sort of methodology to increase the
appeal of products or services to design
thinking which is a methodology of
finding new problems and approaching
them in a strategic manner creates a
completely new paradigm and it shifts
the way in which organizations can
perform and we think of it primarily in
terms of culture so when you approach
designing an organization from scratch
and we we work with lots and lots of
startups here in Silicon Valley a lot of
started to come off the Stanford campus
we talked about creating a design
culture our Design Thinking culture and
culture is simply the set of rules that
that define people's behavior
when they you know enter a workplace or
when they live
in western society culture is this
invisible set of guidelines that tell us
how we should act and literally how we
should think when we approach an
organization so if you're starting a
company from scratch creating a design
culture
well while challenging is very doable
when you're in an existing organization
we'll talk about that in a second we've
had a couple of webinars and
transformation of organizations and
teams but let's just talk for the moment
up about creating a culture in a new
organization what kind of a culture do
you want to create well in design we
start with this notion of creative
confidence David Kelly who's one of the
senior professors here at Stanford also
started a company called IDEO which is
probably the world's most famous
international design and innovation firm
it's also the founder of the d.school he
just gave a TED talk on this subject
because what we're finding with the
Disco's were bringing students and
graduate students from all of the seven
schools at the University School of
Medicine School of Law High School of
Business School of Education and there's
no previous design experience and we run
them through what we call bootcamp and
then they take a d.school class
typically on a subject of their choice
virginia-class where we're designing
products in African Africa for you know
the distant disadvantage of the
developing world we're doing other you
know products where we're classes where
we're designing designing services or
interventions in other parts of the
country for various problems like the
childhood obesity problem so they take
these classes and they leave in there
almost of every single student reports
some kind of a transformation and we ask
them what happened they say something to
the effect of I got my confidence back
that I'm a creative person or I got my
creativity back but it's one of these
interesting things where I think we
probably all felt we were more creative
when we were kids when we were young and
we didn't know that there were rules and
we weren't embarrassed about being goofy
we
that sort of creative confidence and
then unfortunately through the process
of being educated in our Western society
we lost our ability to access this kind
of thinking and one of the most
important things you do in the Design
Thinking culture is create an
environment where people's creativity is
not only nurtured it's required
it's demanded of people to give a ok
solution or a pretty good solution is
not enough you need to give a creative
solution so I was at Apple for seven
years not I've actually not while Steve
Jobs was there I joined just before just
after he was fired by the board and I
left just before he returned so I was
called that time so I was at Apple
between jobs but um the the thing about
Apple even when Steve wasn't there and
certainly when he was if you've read the
autobiography that or the biography that
Walter Isaacson wrote Steve demanded
insanely great products and insanely
great is the same sort of principle we
use at the d.school it's got to be
creative it's got to be incredible it
has to be delightful has to be something
when you see it it truly does knock your
socks off and when you ask people to do
that kind of work and you give them the
tools to access their creative
creativity they develop a new sense of
themselves so the most important thing
about this culture this is a culture of
creativity and the ability to feel like
you can exhibit your best and most
creative self it's in fact that it's
demanded and supported when you go to
work the next thing is a culture of
collaboration and we call it radical
collaboration this is a you know these
are pictures from the early version of
the d.school you can see they're still
sort of two by fours in the background
it's a very raw space it's a very open
space is very malleable
this was actually pictures back when we
were just in a temporary trailer but
what you'll see in this picture if you
know these folks is the the gentleman
with the moustache and gray hair and
glasses in the front right is Terry
Winograd professor Winograd is one of
the really big guns in computers
one of the fathers of artificial
intelligence with Marvin Minsky and one
of the inventors of the human-computer
interaction field in the far far corner
of the gentleman gregor gentleman on the
directly diagonal opposite him in the
back left that is professor brain Roth
who's one of the top kinematics
professors in the world is the multiple
honor a PhDs from universities
everywhere he does math that literally
no one at Stanford can understand the
woman with the big smile in the middle
Tina Selig who's just written a new book
on creativity by the way which has just
come out is a professor in the
management science and engineering
program so these three professors from
completely different schools in the
university are collaborating obviously
happily on a prawn they're a class that
they're teaching Michael berry the
person in the front and the woman
diagonal back from him Nicole Kahn are
both principals in the design firm
called point forward which does human
centered design research so these five
people are the are the the teaching
staff of a class radically collaborating
across computer science mathematics
human centered design innovation
management science and creating the
class for students which is an
incredible experience when we talk about
radical collaboration as part of this
culture of design thinking we really
mean radical we mean bringing people in
from the field sales organization people
from finance people from a radical
collaboration isn't getting four
different kinds of designers or
engineers together that's that's just
something you should do anyway for good
project teams but radical collaboration
is truly bringing people in from
different parts of the organization and
also from your customer base co-creation
through what we we start with will call
empathy and need finding co-creation
with your customers is essential part of
this process so if you have a place
that's naturally creative that nurtures
and fosters interaction between
different kinds of people people who
normally don't interact together and you
combine that with what we can
sitter is the most important thing a
culture of empathy empathy for your
customers empathy for the needs you're
trying to solve empathy for the big
question why do we matter what is our
mission in the world and who are we
trying to impact we start with empathy
in all of our projects briefs we assume
we don't know what we are trying to
solve although we might have anything
might say well it's childhood obesity
it's a problem we want to work on it we
don't understand how to intervene and we
start by interviewing kids we start by
interviewing parents and we interview
doctors and other experts but primarily
we go directly to the source of the
problem because what we find is in
almost every single case the definition
of the problem is incorrect I've been
doing professional design consulting for
about 25 years and I can tell you that
in 25 years now single client has come
in the front door my consulting firm is
called design to matter by the way the
never they've never come in with the
right problem the problem is always
framed too narrowly and it's framed in
the case of a symptom not a root cause
and so empathy work need finding of the
cultural anthropology the ethnography
that we do is critical to creating this
environment where Design Thinking
thrives of course it's the culture of
ideas if you come to the d.school or you
come to any of the design firms that use
these processes in the outside world you
will see walls and walls and walls
unfortunately full of post-its it's a
very non ecological method of problem
solving we do use brainstorming we use
biomimicry we use forced morphologies or
morphological analysis we use mind
mapping rays all sorts of techniques to
create a huge huge number of ideas for
the solutions that were solutions for
the ideas that we're trying to solve we
really think that the evidence is clear
and we can point you to many many
studies if you choose from a large
number of ideas you will choose better
and so we our idea junkies in this
culture and then we believe in a sort of
bias to action you can
have smart people in a room thinking
about solutions but you can build your
way forward you can make things so we're
Design Thinking culture a culture 2d
school or culture in an organization
that you're trying to transform should
fundamentally be a culture of
prototyping you should you should be
building very low resolution very poorly
made examples of possible solutions to
the problem you're working on and these
are not designed to be in fact solutions
are just designed to be things to
promote questions because the questions
go back out into the empathy work and
that circular relationship between
trying to understand and frame the need
prototype and partial solutions asking
people if these are the things that they
were thinking that they wanted and going
back and back and back through that
cycle of iteration is one that really
really I think helps people understand
what it is that they're trying to do in
it so if you have a culture that that
values ideas and collaboration that
starts with a you know come a deep
understanding of human needs and then
assuming that it doesn't know anything
builds its way forward you have created
what we consider to be the most
important thing which is a culture of
design thinking and there's a great
great quote that I like to use a lot
this is from Alan Mulally who's the CEO
of Ford I think he's just about to
retire but he was you know Fortas one of
the few auto companies that was the only
auto company that didn't take a bailout
it has been fairly successful throughout
all the difficulties it recognized that
it was not connecting with its customers
you know long before the other us our
automobile companies did and it decided
you know to do something about it and
they went through a range of different
reengineering sort of systems that hired
some consultants in the consultant said
well you don't have the right product
development system so they put a new
product development system in then they
said well you don't have the right
process for you know managing your
inventory and they put that in they did
all these process changes and nothing
seemed to change the way Ford was
running
and Alan oily was in I was walking
through one of the engineering buildings
and one of the young engineers had put
this sign up I've just printed it out
and put it up in the in the break room
and the sign said culture eats processed
for lunch and the CEO sought out this
young man and sort of heard the story
and the story was basically look well
you keep changing the process around
here and that's fine we can if you want
five twelve gates we're going to five
tool gates 41-7 we can have seven you
want four we can have four if you want
us to do TQM or Six Sigma we can do all
that stuff but basically nobody around
here cares about cars we're not a car
culture we we seem to be a culture that
cares more about you know counting beans
and managing process
Moli Lee really took that to heart and
he changed the way he was organizing the
company and the way he managed it
because he realized the culture this
invisible set of rules of what we do and
how we behave when we come to work in
this case to Ford was really the most
important thing for him to manage the
process would take care of itself that
there were lots of smart people who can
make sure that processes were managed
well and the toll gates were followed
but that if nobody cared about the most
important thing the thing that really
mattered cars making cars that connected
with Ford fires in making cars that
brought back that you know kind of
excitement of the Ford Mustang or really
you know made the connection with people
so people would say wow if Ford went out
of business that would really matter to
me right so he changed the way he was
managing the organization and it became
a much healthier much more passionate
car culture they do radical
collaboration they've broken down a lot
of asylums between design engineering
styling you know field sales they've
connected more deeply with customers
about what are the things you make you
want to stay loyal to a Ford the Ford
brand or the fourth badge and they've
really really pushed hard on trying to
build this culture into every part of
the organization and I love this quote
this was a something that was told by
Allen and Itachi that here at Stanford
and I love the quote because I think it
really captures what we're trying to do
we're not saying when we say you know
switch to a Design Thinking paradigm
that you have to stop doing other things
you're doing the other things you're
doing a typically process driven and
probably very important but never
mistake the process for a culture and in
fact you know the we are not the strong
proponents of any particular process we
do have a process diagram we start with
empathy then we redefine the problem
then we do aviation then we do
prototyping then we start in the
iteration process and when we go back to
finding a new point of view in a drink
I've left that process diagram out of
this presentation on purpose because I
really want to focus more on a culture
or a mindset if you were creating a
brand new company or trying to transform
your own you got to ask yourself what is
it that we do and why does anybody care
what is it what what makes it important
and why does it matter and then you have
to try to build these processes around
that culture so that if you have a
design culture they values ideas and
creativity it can flourish now I mean it
all sounds nice and it seems somewhat
simplistic when you describe it it's
actually incredibly difficult to do this
is a this is a quick summary from a
paper that Professor Bruce Hyman is an
associate professor of international
business at San Francisco State
University he and I wrote a paper that
was given at a conference in Japan in
2007 and he studied how these ideas
about design and creativity and radical
collaboration get blocked in
organizations quite a few people come to
Stanford take webinars take our master
class with a series called the master
class and
we teach Design Thinking to executives
we have other executive programs boot
camps and things people come here they
take these classes they go back to their
organizations they work very hard to
transform them but it does not it does
not take it does not happen we've looked
at this problem and we've identified at
least three significant places where
these types of transformations get
blocked the first one is is a very
personal one it's a conceptual block
conceptual blocks then some of this
language comes from a guy named James
Adams who wrote a book called conceptual
block busting a guide to better ideas
professor Adams is a professor emeritus
here at Stanford one of the guys who
began the design thinking and sign
division here at Stanford back in the
70s you need to identify these
conceptual blocks and they represent
primarily personal challenges in the
organization conceptual blocks impact
the universe of perceived actions your
own blocks impact what you believe is
possible and the blocks come in four
versions intellectual perceptual
emotional and cultural but in
organizations their primary
organizational culture that make you
believe that certain things are not
possible
they cannot happen and because of those
blocks the diffusion of Design Thinking
you know can often fail then there's
semantic blocks or semantic gaps this is
more of an organizational challenge
people use different words to mean the
same thing people use the same words to
mean different things very small
differences matter when accounting talks
about numbers and when engineering talks
about numbers they really are not
talking about the same subject although
the words might seem to be the same and
and because a Design Thinking requires
these highly diverse radical
collaboration teams
these teams are very subject to
misunderstanding each other and not not
being able to function because they
simply don't share common language or
even common outcomes if second soft
confining in fact engineers and they say
I don't know what the marketing guys do
it just make PowerPoint slides and the
marketing people say I don't know what
the engineers do they never communicate
to us they never make presentations not
recognizing that an engineer views their
output to be an object and maybe hub
person in marketing often abused their
their work product their output to be
concepts embody the n-side of a very
well structured presentation so Samantha
gaps can often trip up organizations as
they move into multidisciplinary work
reticle collaboration and they discover
that people neither understand nor value
the same things from different parts of
the organization and then finally
there's just social barriers and usually
describes the you know like a engineers
need engineers with engineers eat lunch
with engineers marketing people eat
lunch with marketing people or finance
people leave lunch by themselves it's
it's just not common in organizations
for people to socialize across the aisle
was interesting just to diverge slightly
into politics it was an interesting
article I think in The New Yorker last
last month about what's going wrong in
Washington and it used to be that in
Washington DC senators when they were
elected moved to Washington lived in
Washington and had you know social
interactions with other congressmen
senators congressmen and Senators from
across the aisle they would you know
play golf together they would go to
dinner together their families knew each
other so even though they were pulled
from different political parties there
was some kind of social lubrication that
allowed an informal communication to
occur and there was much less gridlock
nowadays because of the demands of
running for political office and raising
money no one actually lives in
Washington they fly in have a temporary
you know apartment or something they
stay in fly back to their districts to
raise more money and said
this social informal socialization is
occurring the same thing is true in
companies that send it's a challenge of
networks you don't have any information
outside the network of people that you
work with and typically those networks
are functionally based but when you
think about the kinds of projects and
challenges you face in most organization
functional solutions are inadequate you
need systems-level solutions so there's
a lot of big there's a lot of big issues
when it comes to creating these cultures
of innovation and cultures of design
thinking but there are solutions to each
of these so let's let's kind of get the
zoom back again out to what it was what
were the big questions we were asking
most organizations spend all of their
time looking at how to capture the value
of goods and services that they provide
and I'm sure many of you have been
through this these processes Six Sigma
is very popular what is very popular you
know in early part of the 2000s great
way of capturing more value and making
sure that you get rid of variations so
that all the products and services are
the same or before Six Sigma is total
quality management and now everybody's
talking about lean startups and lean
development and agile development these
are all new systems but when you really
break them all down and they're all very
valuable of course they'll approach the
problem with slightly different points
of view they really break down into
things that are just assuming you have a
product or a service that is valued by a
customer
how can you extract more and more and
more value from that product or service
but the real question is how much time
you're spending on value creation design
thinking is about this side of the
equation much more so than it's about
value capture now you can capture more
value when you tie your products more
specifically to the needs and emotions
of your customers but fundamentally
design thinking is a methodology for
looking at the value creation side of
the equation and in value creation you
know you look towards anything one of
the reasons everybody
starting to talk about design as they're
looking at companies like Apple and
Harley and BMW and others who are
winning by design and they're saying
where's it coming from
where are they getting all these good
design ideas well of course
partly beginning them from their
designers design is the one part of an
organization just traditional design
making you know excellent products
beautiful and better that's the one part
of the organization whose sole focus is
the organic growth of the company by
providing new and different products in
the product line you know that the
company is interested in and when you
think about it it's it's surprisingly
monotonic I was seven years at Apple I
never designed a teddy bear at Apple I
never designed a toaster I never
designed an automobile despite the fact
that everybody seems to think they're
designing a TV there and we're not
they'd never designed a TV
they just do one thing they design
computers big ones small ones handheld
ones ones it go in your pockets it's a
very very simple business model but it
has a strong core based in design and so
the value creation side you got to ask
yourself how much of your day how much
of your working day working week working
month
jerk jerk take out your your you know if
your consultant take out your timesheet
if you're somebody who just likes to
journal or just has a complicated
calendar go look over your calendar and
tell me how much time did you spend the
value capture side of your business and
how much time you spend in the value
creation and my guess is you're going to
discover that you spend not nearly
enough time thinking about the big
question because value creation is how
you approach the problem of how are we
going to do we matter what is the
purpose of this business how does this
business function to delight our
customers in a way that gives us just a
significant strategic advantage which is
sustainable then there's a whole
sustainable strategic advantage Michael
Porter riff on design thinking which I
think but you know we could say for a
different a different talk but but when
you look at organizations and for
instance Apple just reported
last week up off you know 150% more iPad
sold than the previous quarter and
almost double their net profit
it's a juggernaut at this point and it
can't be stopped because no one else was
asking the questions how do we create
value how do we delight our customers
everybody else was asking the questions
how do we make another one of the thing
we've already made right and so they
lost connection with the reason that
they would matter so then the other you
know so the other dialogue or the other
duality is um you know are were you
doing the right are you doing things
right are you doing things right in your
organization it's kind of another
version of value capture but but really
this is the process question do we have
a good process are we doing things right
are we hitting our tool gates are we
managing our process does everybody know
where they are in the process so that
we're a coordinated organization and
those are all really really important
questions but bigger than those
questions is the questions are you doing
the right thing doing things right is
about execution doing the right thing
that's really about read that's the
redefining and reframing the problem
that you're working on in design we use
the empathy step to create what we call
a point of view the point of view is not
instant in science we have a hypothesis
and then we go out and we get data and
we prove the hypothesis right or wrong
in design we have a thing we call a
point of view which we define as a need
plus a user plus an insight so I talked
to my users and I understand who they
are what what is this when I talk about
a market a market is just a bunch of
people who buy the same stuff and talk
to each other who are they what do they
love what do they care why do they buy
this and that's something else what
don't they buy what what would they want
in addition to what we already offer if
I understand the people and their needs
and I have an insight oh maybe this part
of you know their needs really is
unserved yet or maybe there's a latent
need under the thing they tell me maybe
there's something that's latent if I'm
doing that kind of work I'm really
working on doing the
saying I'm making sure that I'm getting
on I'm getting the ball to go down the
right side of the mountain because once
I start the ball all the doing things
right processes you know take over and
once that bug is going down the hill
anyway it's going to just keep going I
mean nobody's going to stop it so I want
to make sure I let the ball go on the
right side of the hill
that's a 360 degree problem because I
can let it go on the left or the right
or in the middle of the the back or
anywhere in between and boy that is the
most important question you should be
wrestling with not are we ready for the
you know next tollgate review the
question that every point along the way
should be have we redefined the problem
are we heading for a blue ocean have we
framed it in a way that's not about the
symptoms but it's truly about a root
cause and are we getting the ball on the
right side of the mountain
because once we let go we know what
happens and then there's of course
managing the present system er it's the
immediate need which you have to get
done today and tomorrow and it's always
the emergency situations that Drive 90%
of what's on your to-do list I bet it's
the same thing with me it's the same
thing with everybody every busy person I
know but managing the president is
nothing like creating a future and you
are being paid most likely to not just
manage immediate needs but to figure out
emergent needs what is happening what is
the long tail what if what are the
patterns that are emerging in your
industry or in the problem set that
you're working on that require the kind
of step back big-picture thinking
pattern matching but only an expert like
yourself can do and can only do if you
have a moment to reflect on it so as
you're making your to-do list make sure
there's a category called
doing the right thing creating the
future you know and and value creation
because if you don't have tasks assigned
to those topics my guess is the the
tyranny of the present
the emergencies of the moment will
probably end up taking up a hundred
percent of your time give you a quick an
example and then we'll get some get to
some questions
we're working with a very large
organization probably the largest
component supplier in the automotive
field and they defined their businesses
as we make components we make sensors we
make some products out of those things
and we have some standalone devices that
reom that we supply is part of this
ecosystem and we're the largest supplier
we know exactly what we're doing and
after that we went through some workshop
activities with them we determined that
what was happening in their market was
that components returning into system
sensors were turning into smart networks
products for turning into services and
experience and standalone devices were
being you know connected to the cloud
and as we as we sort of dissected their
industry and really the huge huge
changes that are occurring in the auto
industry there's more bandwidth exam be
more bandwidth between your car and the
cloud than there is right now not going
into your house by a 20/20 there are
more sensors and sensor networks in your
car already than exist in your home
range per cell so it's one of the most
sophisticated electronic environments
that you live and operate in and all of
these things while they could represent
threats are actually huge opportunities
for new for new businesses when you move
from components to systems systems
create the possibility of new alliances
Xbox in your car right we've already got
Microsoft in your car through you know
entertainment systems but Xbox Sony
PlayStation's and other things will of
course be in your car in the next 10
years it's just a matter of how we're
going to do that safely smart networks
give us the opportunity to do a software
layer there's already a couple million
lines of code running inside your
automobile but the software layer that
makes that accessible to new api's and
new applications create a whole new
marketplace for this organization when
they had never thought of when you move
from you know serve from products to
services and experiences you just have
hundreds more touch points with your
customer
and any organization you know that does
any good is constantly looking for
opportunities to touch their customers
to light their customers and have more
interactions for their customers so
services and experience give you that
and of course the cloud just opens up a
massive computing resources we're
working here at Stamford on autonomous
vehicles you've probably seen the DARPA
vehicle that when the DARPA challenge
about five six years ago we have new
vehicles now that drive by themselves
navigate by themselves fly-by-wire cars
all sorts of amazing things
the autonomous vehicle problem is a very
difficult problem to solve if you have
to do all the computing in the car
because it's a difficult issue but when
you connect the car to the cloud and you
have infinite compute resources there
plus you have awareness of where every
other car and the road is autonomy turns
out to be a relatively simple problem so
these are ways in which this company and
very traditional old-line you know they
make brake pads they make sensors then
you know they make penny coil pressure
sensors they make you know fuel pumps
can transform the organization that they
are obviously they'll need to learn new
skills and and excellences they'll need
to develop new core competencies but if
they can do that they will probably
maintain their dominance in the industry
and if they don't a new competitor will
probably emerge and take much of their
market so I'll close with my favorite
quote from Alan Kay a computer scientist
who is Atari and Apple and IBM in other
places is the best way to predict the
future is to invent it I guess I'd turn
this around and say if you aren't
inventing the future somebody else is
and and you need to be aware of the fact
that nothing stays the same in the world
that is this complex so I'll at this
point maybe turn it back to Karissa and
she's going to talk to you a little bit
and then we'll take some questions great
thank you so much bill and yes I just
want to remind everyone we'll be hanging
around and we'll answer most of the
questions live with Bill so please
submit those well I'm speaking so that
we can
a nice Q&A session offend so at the
Stanford center for professional
development we've been delivering
education to industry for over 40 years
and we've been creating these education
programs to address the career-long
learning needs of professionals managers
and executives and industry we're really
pleased to be collaborating with Bill to
create the innovation master series
which happens to be occurring on the
Stanford campus this June the good news
is that this course is also available
online because we are sold out for June
but wanted to just give you a little bit
of background about why we did this you
know the faculty are really passionate
and engaged and it's approximately three
days worth of material where faculty
will take you through the problem
solving tools and problem finding
frameworks that you heard about from
bill today that have been pioneered by
the Design Group and the d.school here
at Stanford we created this program for
managers business leaders and decision
makers faced with this daunting task of
retooling and revitalizing their
enterprises and here you can get a
better sense of who might benefit from
attending particularly anyone working on
skunk works projects leaders that are
really faced with turnaround situations
and many others we created the program
because we've been hearing for quite
some time how organizations struggle to
make innovation routine and sustainable
in today's business environment
companies continue to be challenged to
do and implement more projects with
fewer resources and here you can see
some of the key takeaways that can help
you navigate these business challenges
to impact the long term success of your
organization one of the unique aspects
of this program is the faculty and in
fact both in the online as well as the
campus session which we do at least once
a year in June the faculty are quite
heavily engaged
and here's it was sort of a who's-who
lineup of folks that are working on
solving wicked problems like some of the
challenges you heard about from bill
today so now I'd like to take a quick
moment to do a poll if you could
indicate your level of interest in
learning about the Design Thinking
course whether it's online or if you're
interested in pursuing a certificate on
the topic that would be really helpful
and we'll just keep the polls open for
just a moment I think so much really
appreciate your feedback on them and
with that I just want to pose this we've
we've been collaborating with several
faculty to create a new certificate on
innovation it'll be an online-only
certificate there are some details here
we're hoping to launch this in the fall
and if you think about sort of the
innovation master series that bill leads
a sort of a master's class to give you
kind of exposure to various tools and
techniques the certificate program will
be much more of a sort of go to work and
do some things in your current
environment that you're that you're
struggling in so with that I'd like to
close and take just a couple moments to
field some questions so the first
question I have your bill is and why is
it that companies don't attempt to
capture the values shared amongst the
organization to address conceptual block
semantic gaps and social barriers don't
you think this would enhance culture and
build external value yeah that's a great
question I think I I think they would
absolutely create value across any
organization if they could have some
more sharing between the silos you know
I just there's oh probably a lot of
reasons why it gets back to a culture
of a culture of expertise the reason we
create these functional Cylons is
because each function wants to develop
an expertise inside its own area of
knowledge and that's that's true for
every function inside any organization
you know there were lots of attempts of
you know functional organizations or
matrix management and management around
projects it's really really difficult
when you get more than a few people in a
room and you have our you have hundreds
of thousands of people to organize you
know company the size of General Motors
or IBM to share knowledge across these
silos is probably one of the biggest
challenges and there are many new
software tools out there people are
using wiki's people are using the
internet and other and very flexible
ways of sharing knowledge but it's a
huge issue you know I think that one of
the most silo places in the world isn't
is a University right I talk about seven
schools here at Stanford with a Business
School of School of Education School of
Law School of Medicine that lets real
humanities and people in those schools
are incredibly well educated in their
field they are the top people
researchers and contributors in their
field of knowledge and they isolate
themselves in these literally ivory
towers sometimes to protect and defend
their expertise in Stanford you know we
had a design program at Stanford since
the early 60s but it wasn't particularly
well known or was it particularly you
know well supported on campus because it
was a multidisciplinary by nature and it
involved most exactly from lots of
different places and if you're a young
faculty member and you want to get
tenure and you want to you know get your
PhD in your research money you don't you
don't succeed by doing lots of things
with other groups you succeed by staying
inside your your silo and pushing
knowledge forward in one very specific
and typically very narrow error area all
of this changed with two things here at
Stanford John Hennessy is the president
of Stanford for about ten over a decade
now came in and he was both a top
computer scientist and certainly it's
very specialized in his silo but also an
entrepreneur who had built successful
companies and realized that in order to
actually win the game you have to
collaborate
and so he's been pushing very very hard
sometimes with faculty resistance
there's an article in The New Yorker
about this just recently to open the
university to a more collaborative
environment and you know for most people
I think do that is a very positive thing
it certainly has a lot of design and
design thinking to flourish here we also
have a Dean Dean Plummer who's a very
big thinker and thinks that the
interesting problems lie between the
disciplines and that the new knowledge
will be created when you collide biology
and mechanical engineering or you
collide nanotechnology you know and
sensors so these two leaders have really
changed the culture here they've managed
the not the process by which we
collaborate there's no process we just
do stuff and if it works we do it some
more if the students love it we do it
even more because Stanford is a very
student-centered organization but
without the leadership of Dean Plummer
and John Hennessy president Hennessy
this kind of culture could not thrive
here so I think the solution in many of
these cases is leadership whether it's
leadership of your project and the way
you model this kind of behavior for your
project team or leadership of your
organization if you run one you need
someone at the top who is going to say
collaboration is not only important it's
demanded and you can't sit this one out
guys this isn't just a new fad you have
to play because in order to succeed in
business we need to kind of design an
innovation that comes from this kind of
it's kind of behavior and so I think
it's the change of a leadership at
Stanford that's shown me that even a
very siloed organization can be
successful and break down the semantic
gaps and the other organizational
barriers to this kind of behavior
thank you Bill well I think we've run
out of time for our live questions but
there's a few questions still remaining
in the queue and we will answer those
before we exit so I want to thank you so
much for joining us today
as we mentioned earlier this
presentation will be made available
Stacey will be sending out the link to
the replay I mean you can also check our
YouTube channel and you know in a week
or so if you'd like to print out PDFs of
today's presentations please select the
handouts icon located in the top
navigation bar
and please feel free to get in touch
with any one of us if you have
additional questions i'm i think our
contact details are in the attendees tab
thanks so much